Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the Langfocus channel,
and my name is Paul.
Today, we're going to
look at the differences
between two languages that many
people mistakenly think are the same,
Russian and Ukrainian.
The misconception that Russian
and Ukrainian are the same
might stem from the fact that Russian
is widely spoken in Ukraine.
The numbers differ depending on the survey,
but according to one 2015 survey
60% of Ukrainians consider
Ukrainian their native language,
15% consider Russian to
be their native language
and 22% consider both to
be their native languages.
These numbers do not include Crimea,
which has been annexed by Russia,
or parts of the eastern provinces
of Donetsk and Luhansk,
which are not currently
under Ukrainian control.
Those areas have a
Russian-speaking majority.
It's also worth noting that most Ukrainian
speakers can also speak Russian,
even if it's as a second language.
Some people may hear Ukrainians speaking
Russian and think to themselves,
"Wow, Ukrainian is so similar to Russian".
But, what they should say to themselves is,
"Wow, Russian is so similar to Russian".
On top of that some people use a mixture of
Ukrainian and Russian called Surzhyk,
and they may not be consciously aware of
which elements are Ukrainian
and which are Russian.
This code-mixing may also blur the
lines between Ukrainian and Russian.
However, despite the sometimes unclear
delineation between the two languages,
Standard Russian and Standard Ukrainian
are clearly distinct,
and the vernacular speech of most
people is also clearly distinct.
Both languages developed from
the Old East Slavic language,
which comprised a set of
mutually intelligible dialects
spoken within the Federation of Rus,
which later came to be
referred to as Kievan Rus.
These Old East Slavic
speakers are thought of
as the ancestors of today's
Russians, Ukrainians, and Belarusians.
When Kievan Rus fell, the Slavic tribes
were divided into two separate states,
and the Old East Slavic dialects
in those separate states
began to grow apart from each other
and undergo different influences.
Tribes to the east came under the
rule of the Grand Duchy of Moscow,
and their dialects evolved into Russian.
Standard Russian, which is dominant today,
developed with more influence
from Old Church Slavonic,
the old Slavic literary language which
differed from vernacular dialects.
Also, under Peter the Great,
who aimed to turn Russia into a
major Western power.
Russian adopted a significant
amount of vocabulary
from French and other European languages.
Tribes to the west came under
the Grand Duchy of Lithuania,
and then the Polish-Lithuanian
Commonwealth.
Standard Ukrainian was based
on spoken vernacular
specifically the southeastern dialects,
and lacks much of the Old Church
Slavonic influence that Russian has.
Ukrainian also underwent
a lot of Polish influence
due to geographic proximity
and Polish political control,
with Polish being a lingua franca
for a period of time.
This is especially true in
Western Ukrainian dialects.
Now, let's cut to the chase and start
looking at the languages themselves.
Vocabulary.
Russian and Ukrainian share
about 62% lexical similarity.
I personally found this
number surprisingly low.
Ukrainian has a higher lexical similarity
with Polish, Slovak and Belarusian,
than it does with Russian,
especially with Belarusian.
Even among very basic words
there are lots of differences.
The word for paper.
In Ukrainian: papir,
and in Russian: bumaga.
I suspect the Ukrainian word
was borrowed from Polish,
which in turn borrowed it from German.
The word for sugar:
tsukor - sakhar
Both of these words are cognates that
trace back to Proto-Indo-European.
The Russian word traces
back to Old East Slavic,
while the Ukrainian word
was borrowed from Polish,
which borrowed it from German.
The word for money: hroshi - den'gi.
This Russian word is a borrowing
from a Turkic language,
but Russian also has a cognate
of the Ukrainian word: groshi,
which refers to pennies or
a small amount of money,
and is also the name of
some older types of coins.
The word for mourning:
ranok - utro
The word for bottle: plyashka,
this word traces back to
Polish and then to German,
butylka, this Russian word is
also a loanword from Polish
which in turn got it from French.
In Polish, "butelka" is
a more general word,
while "flaszka" is more for hard liquor.
Also, the names of months are different.
In Russian, the names of months came
from Latin via Old Church Slavonic.
In Ukrainian, the names of the months
are original vernacular Slavic words.
For example, January.
In Russian : yanvar'
and in Ukrainian: sichen'
and February:
fevral' - lyutyy, and so on
As with most languages
which are closely related,
there are lots of false friends
in Russian and Ukrainian.
Words that appear to have the same meaning,
but actually don't.
"chas", this Ukrainian word means time.
"chas", this Russian word means hour.
"harbuz", this means pumpkin.
"arbuz", and this means watermelon.
"nedilya", this means Sunday.
"nedelya", and this means week.
"svaryty", and this means to scold
in the imperfective form.
"svarit'", and this means to boil
in the perfective form
"svit", this word means world.
"svet", this means light.
This Russian word does have a
secondary meaning of "world",
but only in some fixed expressions.
"layaty", this means to scold
"layat'", this word means to bark.
Orthography and pronunciation.
Both languages use varieties
of the Cyrillic alphabet,
but there are a number of differences
between the Russian variety
and the Ukrainian variety.
First, Ukrainian has this letter,
which represents the sound g,
but Russian doesn't have this letter.
In Russian g is represented by this letter,
In Ukrainian, this letter is
normally pronounced as h.
Next, Ukrainian has this letter
which represents the sound i,
but Russian doesn't have this letter.
In Russian this letter
represents the sound i,
Ukrainian has this letter which
represents the sound ye.
In Russian this letter represents
the similar sound ye.
But, in Ukrainian this letter
represents the sound e,
and in Russian that sound e
is represented by this letter,
a letter which isn't used in Ukrainian.
Russian has this letter which
represents the sound e,
a letter which Ukrainian doesn't have.
Instead, in Ukrainian this letter
represents the equivalent sound,
in addition to the sound e.
For example, the
words meaning "soap",
in Russian "mylo"
and in Ukranian "mylo".
Ukrainian has this letter
to represent the sound yi
but Russian doesn't have this letter.
In Russian, this sound is represented
by a combination of two letters.
Russian has this letter
to represent the sound yo,
but Ukrainian doesn't use this letter,
instead it uses a
combination of two letters.
Russian has this special letter
that doesn't represent a sound,
but indicates that the previous consonant
is in it's hard consonant form
in a context where you would
expect the soft consonant form.
Ukrainian doesn't use this letter,
but instead uses an apostrophe
after the consonant.
So, in Russian,
it's written like this "ob"yekt",
while in Ukrainian,
it's written like this "ob"yekt".
Grammar.
The concepts of grammar, in Russian and
Ukrainian, are generally the same.
They both have three genders
masculine, feminine, and neuter.
They both have almost
the same set of noun cases,
that apply to adjectives
and pronouns, as well.
They share the same major
verb conjugations, and so on.
But, the exact word forms
are often different,
or at least not entirely the same.
Let's look at the different case forms
for the noun meaning
"head"  in both languages.
These words are cognates.
In Russian: golova,
and in Ukrainian: holova
These are both in the
nominative singular form.
Notice that in the nominative singular,
they are spelled exactly the same,
but sound fairly different.
The first consonant is
one that I mentioned before,
which normally sounds like g in Russian,
but h in Ukrainian.
In Russian, the o vowel is frequently
reduced to a or swha a when unstressed,
while in Ukrainian it
tends to not be reduced.
Now, looking at the case forms,
one thing to notice is that the case
endings have some different vowels.
Some are different letters
representing equivalent sounds.
For example, the Russian
genitive singular "golovy",
and the Ukrainian
genitive singular, "holovy".
Others represent different sounds.
For example, the Russian
dative singular "golove",
and Ukrainian dative singular "holovi".
Another thing to notice is that
while Ukrainian has a vocative case,
Russian does not
The vocative form is the form
you use when you are addressing
or calling someone or something.
The old vocative form
was lost from Russian,
except for a few specific words.
For example, when addressing God.
Bozhe.
It seems that it's being used less and
less in spoken Ukrainian, as well.
But, it's still used by some and
is part of standard Ukrainian.
In Russian, a new vocative form
is apparently starting to develop,
in which the final vowel is dropped,
usually from names and familial words.
For example, "mama" becomes "mam".
But, whether or not it's a genuine
vocative case form is debated.
Another common difference is that
in Russian, the copula - byt'-
the word meaning "to be" is
not used in the present tense
This is often true in Ukrainian too,
which has a lot of dialectal variation.
But, in formal standard speech,
and in western dialects closer to Poland,
the copula is commonly used.
For example, let's look at the
sentences meaning "this is illegal".
In Russian: eto nezakonno.
In Ukrainian, it could be similar:
tse nezakonno.
Or, it might have the copula like this:
tse ye nezakonno
In western Ukraine, it might be like this:
to ye nezakonno
"to ye" is similar to "to jest" in Polish.
Another difference is that Ukrainian
has some additional verb conjugations,
that Russian doesn't have.
In Ukrainian, there's an additional
way to express the imperfective future
that Russian doesn't have.
Take the sentence meaning
"they will be eating"
or "they will eat" in an
imperfective tense.
In Russian: Oni budut yest'.
And now in Ukrainian, first
with an equivalent structure:
Vony budut' yisty.
In both languages, there's the subject
pronoun, the third-person plural,
then the future conjugation
of the verb meaning "to be",
followed by the infinitive
of the lexical verb,
the main verb that supplies
the core meaning.
But, Ukrainian also has
this form: Vony yistymut'.
rather than using
the verb "to be"
a suffix is attached
to the infinitive,
followed by the same future inflection
that appeared on the verb meaning "to be".
This alternate conjugation is called the
imperfective synthetic future tense.
Ukrainian also has a pluperfect
conjugation that Russian doesn't have,
though not everyone uses
it in Ukrainian anymore.
For example, here's a sentence meaning:
"I had been reading this book,
but I forgot its contents".
Ya chytav buv tsyu knyzhku,
ta zabuv yiyi zmist.
The pluperfect is formed
with the past tense perfective
form of the lexical verb,
followed by the past tense of
the verb meaning "to be".
In Russian, the sentence would be:
Ya chital etu knigu no
zabyl yeyo soderzhaniye.
In Russian, the past tense
perfective form of the verb is used,
rather than a special pluperfect form.
This might be a good time
to stop for a moment,
and examine some other differences
between these two sentences,
Before, we saw that the words
for "this" are different,
that was in the neuter nominative form.
Here they are, both in the
feminine accusative form,
and again they take on
slightly different forms.
Next, notice the words
meaning book are cognate,
but with different forms.
The Ukrainian word is
in its diminutive form,
knyzhku,
which is the everyday way to say book.
It can also be said with
the same form as in Russian,
but that would be more formal in Ukrainian.
In Russian, there is
also a diminutive form,
kishka,
it's less common than in Ukrainian,
and is even more informal word for
a book or something like a booklet.
Both words are in the
accusative singular form here.
Notice that the words for
"but" are different.
However, it's worthnoting that the primary
meaning of the Ukrainian word is "and".
and this word "ale" is a
more common word for "but".
And, notice the cognate
words meaning "forgot"
that takes somewhat different forms.
"ee" these are the third-person feminine
singular genitive personal pronouns,
and these words are cognates.
And finally, we see the nouns
meaning content.
The Russian word "soderzhaniye"
consists of the verb "soderzat"
meaning "to contain" plus "anije" a suffix
that forms abstract nouns from verbs.
The Ukrainian word is a simple noun
that isn't composed of these two parts.
Another difference is that Russian,
at least formal Russian,
makes use of active
participles
to give extra information
about a noun or a noun phrase,
while Ukrainian does not.
For example, the phrases meaning
"the woman sitting on the chair".
First, in Russian:
zhenshchina sidyashchaya na stule.
This phrase has an active participant.
But, in Ukrainian this meaning would
be expressed using a relative clause
zhinka, shcho sydyt' ba stil'tsi.
This is like saying,
"the woman that sits on the chair".
That's also how this meeting would be
expressed in daily speech in Russian
zhenshchina, kotoraya sidit na stule.
In a Russian sentence,
the relative pronoun is "kotoraya"
But, in Ukrainian there
are several possibilities,
"kotryy", which is cognate with the
Russian word "yakyy" or "shcho",
as in the sentence above.
And, as a side note, look at the different
forms the word for woman takes.
In Russian, it's "zhenshchina",
while in Ukranian it's "zhinka".
The preposition meaning "on" is the same,
except for slightly
different vowel quality.
And, the word for "chair" are clearly
related, but take on different forms.
In the most basic form,
the nominative singular,
the Russian word is "stule"
and the Ukrainian
word is "stil'tsi".
Here they are in the locative case,
though for Russian, it's often referred
to as the prepositional case.
Now, let's look at one final
sentence and see what we find.
These sentences mean 'I can't go
because I'll be working tomorrow'.
In Russian: Ya ne mogu poyti,
potomu chto zavtra (ya) budu rabotat'.
And in Ukrainian: Ya ne mozhu pity,
tomu shcho zavtra (ya) budu pratsyuvaty.
Word for word, both sentences are:
I-negative-can-go-because-
tomorrow-I-will be-to work.
Notice that the first
two words meaning 'I',
then the 'negative'
are basically the same.
Next, the words meaning 'can' are cognates,
but have grown apart and
are now pronounced differently,
notably the second consonant.
Next, the verbs meaning 'go' are cognates,
they are both perfective infinitive forms.
Both verbs contain a perfective prefix
attached to the imperfective verb.
Next, there's a compound conjunction
meaning 'because' in both languages,
and these parts are cognates.
But, the Russian compound
contains an extra element.
In Ukranian, a different conjunction
"bo" can also be used.
Next, the words for 'tomorrow'
are basically the same.
After that,
we see the subject pronoun again,
but it isn't necessary and can be dropped,
because the subject is clear from
the conjugation of the verb.
Both Russian and Ukrainian
are pro-drop languages
Next, the imperfective future tense
is formed in the same way
with the verb meaning 'to be' as the
auxiliary verb in the future  tense,
followed by the infinitive of the
lexical verb meaning 'to work'.
But, the lexical verbs
themselves are different,
the Ukrainian word was
borrowed from Polish.
Now, remember that Ukrainian
has the alternate way
of saying something in
the imperfective future.
As I'm sure you can see,
Russian and Ukrainian are very
closely related languages
that share a lot of similarities
But, they also have a lot of differences,
some of them minor and some of them major.
Lots of different vocabulary, different
pronunciation, and different word forms,
that have arisen over time
to make the two languages
only partially mutually intelligible
to people who don't have much
exposure to the other language.
But, since most Ukrainian
speakers also speak Russian
or have extensive exposure to it,
asymmetric intelligibility is the norm.
In other words, Ukrainian speakers
can often understand Russian,
while the Russian speaker
doesn't understand Ukrainian,
especially Russian speakers
from outside Ukraine.
The question of the day.
For speakers of Russian and Ukrainian:
How similar do you think
the two languages are?
To what extent can you
understand the other one?
And for other people:
How similar do Russian and
Ukrainian seem to you?
If you enjoyed this video,
be sure to check out Langfocus on
the various social media platforms
like Facebook, YouTube,
Instagram, and Twitter.
And, as always, I want to give a very
special thanks to my patreon supporters,
especially my top tier
patreon supporters,
whose names are right
here on the screen
Many special thanks to them.
And to everyone, thank you for
watching and have a nice day.